joined now by espn espn's own carl
ravage
and carl i don't know if you're a big
pedro serrano fan but i'd be curious
who's your favorite baseball player from
movies or tv shows over the years
now i'm i'm a serrano fan um i i i've
always been loyal to kelly leake
i i think he was as good a baseball
character in a movie as you're gonna
find i kind of was into the things that
that he did i
like the attitude i like the i like the
bike i like the hair i thought the
freckles were cool he kind of
strutted hit the ball further than most
just kind of showed up said i'm here to
kick ass and then i'm going to leave
so i go with probably kelly leake as a
as a baseball
character in a baseball related movie um
yeah but serrano i mean that whole movie
is kind of
religious i was big into the dog that
used to steal the baseballs when it went
over the fence i thought that was kind
of a cool
cool character the babe ruth signed
baseball but um that wasn't a that was
obviously a four-legged creature yeah if
you get a rare off day are you the type
to go see a big blockbuster car like are
you a fast nine guy or are you looking
for the next minari
no menari uh yeah i would say that i'm
not uh and i
i generally i mean i know that uh
my buddy and your buddy adnan i i defer
to my wife the great christino on all
this she could be a movie reviewer so i
generally
fall on the sword of whatever chris
wants to see his movies
um you know i'd say godfather sort of
jaws those types of big movies but i'm
not fast and serious
careers guy at all minari minari works
for for us that type of
that type of film and like most i think
who fall into that category
we're obviously now sort of enamored
with ted lasso
uh we now follow that ted lasso on
twitter we like all of
all of his sayings we like the attitude
we just we love
we love the lasso genre like to uh i'm
glad that the ravaged household is
downloading rating reviewing subscribing
to the cinephile podcast with adnan verk
that's good
keep it uh give it a house of cinna
files over there a long time first time
a long time for a long time we're long
time friends of adnan so we'll we'll
support anything that adnan does
well carl as you know my father a long
time suffering boston red sox fan has
now become entitled with his four world
series absolutely
didn't have expectations going into this
season but i get an email
a text a phone call every time alex
verdugo does
anything at all right i knew though that
when that ball was thrown in yankee
stadium and hit him in the back
that could be a turning point for both
these teams where do you see the red sox
and the yankees now as we head down the
stretch
and that was that was sort of the uh
that was the arrow with
with fire coming out of it it's just
metaphorically with the baseball like
all of a sudden
they've knocked down the giant that is
alex verdugo and the red sox and they're
they're back down to earth is that is
that five out of six now in the bronx
and the red sox struggling here i just
wanted one of those
weird nights in the bronx with the rain
and you go huh maybe this season's going
to change for both these teams
here moving forward and it looks like it
has a couple of days after the deadline
as you know and i know your dad knows
um the red sox had acquired schwarber
and they lost two games
uh the blue jays you know picked up a
really good pitcher
and the yankees picked up two really
good hitters uh both left-handed and the
rays picked up nelson cruz
and they after two two days hadn't lost
any game
so yeah it felt that way and it
continues to kind of feel like the red
sox were teetering
i think that it's it's amazing i think
schwarber
has magnified as opposed to the
attention being on
what he may do for them as just a bat a
left-handed bat
who can help brent throw out because
he's not great against righties and you
could platoon
but i think just the fact they got
schwarber magnifies
some of the deficiencies that we've seen
recently with starting pitching
now for a while nick pavetta was good
last night vivaldi really struggled
i think there's all sorts of concerns
and question marks about
eduardo rodriguez um it's like the
giants
and you can appreciate that there's some
there's just some skepticism
in the fact that the giants are leading
the nl west because the names
are not the dodgers names and they're
not the padres names and their track
records aren't great
well the red sox you know for the most
part nick pavetta's track record
isn't great eduardo rodriguez is coming
off
an injury plagued covid related uh heart
issue
2020 so there's just some skepticism
around him in the last few days that's
only been fueled by their
by their losses and their and their lack
of wins while the other teams are
winning
karl ravitch joins the show espn
baseball tonight ben lyons in for rich
on the rich eisen show
you mentioned schwarber but a bunch of
former cubs chris bryant anthony rizzo
javi baez all on the go all hitting home
runs
in their debuts with these new teams do
you enjoy
seeing the 2016 cubs now kind of moving
on and
finding themselves in different
situations or is an end of an era and
you're like sarah spain and you're just
crying every night watching these guys
elsewhere no i'm all about uh
not necessarily anchoring to teams or
franchises um and faces changing
i'm delighted for those three dudes um
to go and hit home runs in their new
cities i i i'm not
crying but i'm bummed for my guy david
ross i think he's in a he's in a rough
spot
um but i think he's also going to be
able to deal with it i think the
pressure's now off
to win it's a weird year for chicago
because they stunk in the beginning then
then they were in first place and they
had traded you darvish
before the whole thing started you're
like well wait a minute i they're
they're in a trade they're in a cell
mode
like the fact that they're having
success
to me was smoking mirrors the fact that
your dad
didn't have much hope for the red sox
this year uh
i would i would disagree with that i
thought the red sox were
an epic fail i mean the red sox would
orbit last year as just to use movie
language
that was one of the rare movies i walked
out on they they just quit
they didn't try um they had more talent
than most teams did
and last year they just kind of gave up
this year
they're actually hitting the baseball
and catching the baseball and
prior to the race series pitching the
baseball at a level i thought they would
um that's why when you ask who's the
manager of the year in the american
league
to me it's it's tony larussa i mean
there was you talk about skepticism and
and teams that have dealt with huge
injuries all year
and i think have achieved if not over
achieved i thought the red sox were
going to be as
as this good if not if not as good as
the yankees and rays they should have
been last year
and they took the year off carl i just
want to go back to that movie theater
experience where you're watching norbit
and you say you know what
i've had enough yep what was it in
norway
did you saw that you said you know what
i got better things to do
yeah i would there it it was one of
those where you're just kind of waiting
and i've heard this before with people
whether they're playing a round of golf
and you recognize
there's nothing about this particular
round for this person
that's going to improve you could walk
off now and it's going to feel
the same norbit i'd say 30 minutes in
was i've reached the point of no return
there's nothing about this particular
movie that is going to
alter my opinion of it i'm done
i'm ready to sell i think i had probably
bottomed out on the popcorn
and i was like nope i i i can't it's not
it's not gonna turn and i have not heard
from anybody who suggested you know you
missed the last hour 20 you really blew
it
so if you were going to tell me that
i'll go back and try again but i haven't
heard anybody come out and say
yeah you you missed a pivotal
pivotal scene and and as a result you
cost yourself an experience in a movie
theater you otherwise will never be able
to get back i don't know why this brings
me so much joy but just the idea of carl
ravage
with an empty bucket of popcorn being
like norbit i'm disgusted i'm out of
not only that i dragged my i was with i
was with my son sam and his buddy alex
and i said we're out
they probably look at me like wait a
minute we just started
where are we going well you made the
executive decision for the whole family
not i'll meet you so we're an entire
family we don't stand for this we're the
ravaged household we look for menaria we
cannot find norbert
comes out and then the manager comes out
and takes the ball from the pitcher
i'm taking the ball the movie's over
let's go boys out of the game
find another one wow carl ravage joins
the show
ben lyons here filling in for rich on
the rich eisen show
um so let's continue to talk some
hollywood tell me why the dodgers are
not the best team in baseball
well i mean win loss wise they're not i
i do
i i'm certain they're going to end up
that way again
it goes back to the skepticism of um
stephen dugger and brandon crawford
and buster posey and kevin gausman
you know and johnny cueto and then let's
throw out there
walker bueller uh max scherzer
julio aureus clayton kershaw justin
turner
mookie bets you know bellinger uh
you go around you could go around the
dodgers team and for the most part
every one of their names um would be
favored in a in a let's let's go through
position by position
with the exception of posey um generally
gonna probably favor the dodgers
and will smith's really good so i they
will be
they're not now the giants have been
great i don't think the giants are gonna
leave
i think those are your three playoff
teams in the national league
but i think the dodgers win in a series
i think they're better
it's crazy just to see that the amount
of talent they have out here in los
angeles
it's crazy and it is it it's crazy it
means
they are they are every nba team now
that wins championships they
they have stockpiled gross amount of
talent
you know that the let's all get together
and just go to la and play baseball so
we don't really need a shortstop um and
we're pretty good with pitching but
let's add
you know the multiple saw young guy and
somebody who's
athleticism and speed may end up being
the difference in a series
like we saw with mookie betts when they
won it all it was
remember people forget it was his legs
that won that world series or at least
one a critical game
with his secondary leads i think at
first at home when he came in to score
that
that's what trey turner can do now and
then you go down the 405
uh a couple miles uh you know and you
get some traffic it's a couple hours
but the anaheim angels have the most
exciting player of
my generation i mean this this guy
ohtani what he's doing
is just the stuff of legends yet you
don't feel the presence here in the city
of los angeles or even now
in this back half of the of the season
with all the attention being put on him
at the all-star break
you know anaheim not being uh a real
contender a serious contender what do
you think that does to just sort of his
long-term plans in anaheim do you see
ohtani
maybe having a change of scenery in in
coming seasons
i would think of that continues it
shortens his time in anaheim
um i like i i think if you you know you
you look back on
on the history in the pursuit of otani
and the list that he wrote i think when
he was in high school of the things he
wanted to accomplish at certain ages
um and they were lofty including like
having a daughter and a son
and getting married and winning a world
series and being an
mvp all those things are on these lists
that he may come to find that that los
angeles with this team isn't the isn't
the right place for me to accomplish
those goals
um he certainly seems worldly he was
unanimously uh enamored and accepted at
the all-star game for what he was doing
so he's he's making friends throughout
the game
and look moving from country to country
is a very difficult thing but he
seems to have been able to now thread
the needle and
other people have taken note like uh we
would love to have ten of those on our
teams we could find them
he's incredible he's fast he's gifted as
a pitcher and a hitter
he's just everything you'd want so i i
think he strikes you if you're willing
to up and leave a country
and go to uh to play major league
baseball you're willing to up and leave
a franchise and go do it somewhere where
you recognize
those those pinstripe people from new
york is
that seems like something i might want
to investigate uh now that i know about
some of them and see
what new york is about or that team up
the road that has those pretty white and
blue uniforms that that might be
interesting for me
or i want to go live in the middle of
the country and i know how good the
chicago cubs are and i love their
manager i think all those things are
are in play for him i think we do forget
they also play with he also plays with
mike trout and we just haven't been able
to enjoy
the two of them but look the angels are
nowhere near
where those other where those other
teams in that
in that area of the country are they're
not the padres they're not the giants
they're not the dodgers
and i love joe madden and i like his
willingness to do things
but they they they need such an overhaul
of
pitching talent on both the starting and
bullpen staffs that
it's it's not next year it doesn't feel
like it's two years it's just constantly
feels like
i don't know you know you know the big
dig remember the big dig in boston i
know your dad probably does but they had
the big dig going which was the
construction of an underground tunnel
which would allow folks from the west to
drive to logan airport
it took like nine years like the angels
are the big dig of major league baseball
it just takes forever it sounds like
ohtani needs to pull
an orbit and just get out of there and
pull an executive decision and say time
to go that's what it sounds like
i wasn't contractually observated to sit
there and watch the rest of it he is
contractually obligated
to stay and watch the rest of this and
and perform
well your contract i love anymore i love
eddie murphy in a lot of other things
that one just didn't float my boat
uh do you have high hopes for beverly
hills cop four after coming to america
sequel being such a downer yeah i i can
i
again i kind of shut it down um i i like
the car in the in the garage with the
dust on i thought that was cool but i
again two threes and fours uh there's
not a lot
of sequels that that are better than the
original
like to me rocky one was the was a rocky
was the best book i ever read growing up
the book itself was fantastic and the
movie obviously
was great but after that when we started
to introduce
different characters and drago etc like
i'm out but
i'm just not into that but again that's
just one man's opinion
no but carl i i agree with you two
threes and fours
usually not a good look when it comes to
sequels but that's why i've got hope for
you i think you could be a fast guy
because fast 7 8 9 those movies rip carl
[Laughter]
what what part of them rip that i
wouldn't have otherwise enjoyed in one i
mean carl
you're a guy who lives his life one
quarter mile at a time i i get it i
think you'll find
a lot of affinity between you and dom
how is transformer where are we on the
transformer see
they're stuck in like three four five we
got to keep keep it going we got to
bring back everybody bring back tyrese
do mel
dumel's got great cheekbones he never
ages let's bring them back for six seven
eight
and now we got a chance when you and
adnan do things together are you off
is your voice often confused well no
because i speak at the pace of a human
being
and admin is a podcast on time and a
half
so people can make the differentiate
between the two of us because i speak up
batman is the seven inning game and
you're the nine in the game yeah but
yeah but i
i'm a yankees red sox game on espn on a
sunday night i'm gonna draw it out for
about four and a half hours
uh appreciate you taking some time carl
really do and i'm sorry norbert was such
a traumatic experience for you
it's nor [ __ ] excuse me yes i apologize
yeah so you did ben let's review norbit
next time we do this
i think norbit you got to go on amino
hassan's podcast cinephobe where they
take
horribly rated movies and re-watch them
you're perfect for that
this whole baseball you know being the
face of baseball thing doesn't work out
for you on tv you've always got that
you're the best i love you thanks for
taking some time appreciate you
carl ravage joining the show hey you
watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here